[Music]
why don't we is slowly taking over the
world and our hearts let's be honest we
were in need of another boy band but do
you know how hard it is to be a pop star
well you're about to find out don't
forget to hit that notification valves
never miss another video and be sure to
check out our community section for even
more fun now let's check out what why
don't we have to put up with fans just
yup and then they take it from there and
they've worked wonders strict rehearsals
every pop singer needs to rehearse for
their performance as you might expect it
isn't always easy it's been noted that
bands should practice at least one to
two times per week for at least three to
four hours at a time it might not seem
like a lot but it's basically an intense
workout just imagine singing and dancing
at the same time when why don't we are
on tour they also need to have sound
checks before every show this way they
make sure they're checking the sound
equipment as well as the actual
performance for that specific set and
arena you never know what might happen
if you don't do a sound check why don't
we sometimes documents their rehearsals
on Twitter this means the fans get fed
with some of the most hilarious footage
ever and if you're a fan of a musician
you know that footage is very much
appreciated it just shows that
rehearsals can also be fun if you're in
the right company and who doesn't want
to see their fave happy it's unclear
just how much time why don't we spins
rehearsing while on tour but based on
their performances we can say that it's
quite a lot it takes a while to put
everything together after all and not to
mention learning the choreography these
boys definitely work hard simple dance
moves this isn't just a tour thing this
is a brand thing boy bands are often
judged by their minimal choreography
when you compare the choreography of a
girl band like put harmony or little mix
it's pretty clear that male bands aren't
expected to put on a choreography type
of show well unless you're a k-pop group
but this is not a video for that but why
don't we wanted to do something
different so all their performances even
their tour ones have simplistic
choreography that syncs them together as
a group the reason behind the simplistic
dancing is because why don't we consists
of five solo artists yep they are all
pretty much
just on their vocals and not on their
dancing but because the band wanted to
differentiate itself from bands like one
direction they added a tiny bit of
choreography to their performances so
even if they're on tour their
choreography rules have to be included
in a performance it might not seem like
a lot but based on the fact that the
Limelight's fandom is huge the
simplistic moves are definitely working
I mean it's got a very upbeat vibe and
very just happy vibe pre-show rituals
some artists have pre-show rituals it
doesn't matter where they are they're
always doing something before the show
to make sure they have a successful
performance beyond say for example has a
pre-show ritual that takes a few hours
seriously
we're not kidding involves saying a
prayer with everyone in the band and
then stretching she then sits in a
massage chair for an hour thought people
do her hair and makeup
that's her ritual and One Direction used
to do a group huddle in their huddle
they would say something that would
change depending on the continent they
were in so for example they'd sing the
lion sleeps tonight when they were in
South America and why don't we scree
show ritual involves a chance that
highlights the fact that this is just
the beginning for the band
they also chant 1 2 3 why don't we how
adorable is that we bet these type of
chants really bring up the energy and
get the entire band hype and ready to
hit the stage combine that with the next
why don't we quirk and you really have a
complete tour package the handshake it
looks like why don't we just loves to do
their secret handshake in a cue a video
that was clearly taking on their tour
bus you can see Jack and Daniel doing
the band's secret handshake obviously
it's not secret anymore
but by the looks of it they do it quite
often of course this isn't an exactly
strictly forced rule but we've been
having a secret handshake makes them
feel good it's even better because now
they're fans
aka lime lights also do the exact secret
handshake imagine meeting someone on the
street and randomly discovering their
lime lights because they know the why
don't we secret handshake it's part of
the fandom magic and the handshake is
definitely present on their tour and to
be completely honest this secret is
actually pretty cool we love it when
bands create something like this to
unite their fans and make them feel like
part of the family
just imagine doing the secret handshake
with one of the boys it's just adorable
to see them so playful despite the fact
that they're really busy on their tour
can you do the why don't we handshake
try it it was just magic like using
social media although it's not a rule
pretty much all why don't we members use
social media this helps them connect to
their fans as well as it grow their
audience along with having personal
social media why don't we also has a
band account this makes it easier to
post band relevant news even though
they're on tour the account makes
frequent announcements on both Instagram
and Twitter this makes sure fans can
reach them on pretty much all relevant
social media platforms the band doesn't
really take a break from social media
when they're on tour they or their
manager still has to post relevant
information for example you'll often see
posts announcing the next performance
and interacting with the fans sometimes
the band members will also post videos
or photos from behind the scenes either
way social media is an absolute must
during the tour while this is not a must
for their own personal accounts the band
cage needs to be updated and remain
active as much as possible speaking of
social media if you're a part of the
limelight you should definitely create a
Twitter fan account keep up to date with
everything related to why don't we
perfect yeah I think so perfect is one
good I know made for to cleaning rules
okay so what about cleaning living on a
bus doesn't look that fun but living
with five boys might be just a little
bit messy okay okay a lot messy but
there's a strange reason behind that in
a 2018 interview why don't we revealed
they don't have bus cleaners so whenever
they're on a tour bus they basically
have to rely on themselves and we all
know how messy boys are so obviously
this won't work out well but the reason
behind it is the fact that why don't we
wants to remain humble after all pop
stars don't really do tours do they
sometimes it just feels good to clean of
course the bus wasn't always clean their
bus driver had to actually yell at them
because it was so filthy that gave them
some motivation to actually keep the bus
tidy at all times so there you have it
tour rule no cleaners we wonder if this
also means the boys clean their own
rooms when they're back at home
considering how responsible they are
with the tour bus they might
actually be as messy as we thought
[Music]
sharing is caring
why don't we has showed us time and time
again why we should pay attention to
them but if you weren't drawn in by
their talents perhaps this motto might
make you pay more attention they believe
in the concept of sharing is caring no
matter where you are after all they have
to work together as a group and what
better way to do that than to do
everything together we have seen so many
groups fall apart and we're still not
over for harmonies hiatus but why don't
we make sure they're connected with one
another through every aspect of their
work whenever they explore new lyrics
they also share them with each other
along with new chords it allows them to
record music quickly and have every band
member involved with the entire process
we're all familiar with fans that have
fallen apart due to lack of creative
control and way too many differences
with band members well why don't we
definitely doesn't have this issue
because they seem to always make sure
everyone gets creatively fulfilled
not to mention that sharing lyrics and
working together like this makes them
incredibly efficient we love a
hard-working band water water water we
all know that water is extremely
important for us right it gives us
clearer skin and overall just helps us
feel hydrated at all times
well why don't we seems to think so too
in an interview with Ticketmaster why
don't we was asked to give their fans
some advice Danya says they should
always have their vitamins and stay
hydrated
we're pretty sure why don't we follow
those rules on tour too because let's be
honest we all follow those rules plus
the boys have such clear skin it would
be a miracle if it doesn't come from
hydration and skin routine just look at
them they pretty much always look on
point
don't they there has to be a secret to
this and we're pretty sure it involves
water and vitamins just like Daniel said
what we do want to know is exactly what
vitamins they use because we really just
want a bunch just so we can look like
them come on just look how clear their
skin is officially jealous Daniels other
advice was to not drink hose water so
water is definitely on their minds
speaking of water make sure you stay
hydrated
drink a glass right now tor dress code
one thing's for sure why don't we
definitely knows how to dress to impress
they certainly got the style just check
their Instagram but on tour
why don't we pretty much dress it's
comfortable at all times shirts with
slogans and simple jeans seem to be
their thing but when they're on stage
the band does seem to follow a dress
code that makes them look more unified
most of the time they're dressed in all
black if they were wearing another color
all band members have to be dressed in
the same color but what makes why don't
we special is the fact that their dress
code isn't that strict this means each
individual member can experiments with
their clothes and how they want to look
they can put their own individual spin
on the outfit as long as parts of it
match to make them look like a band
that's pretty fair right their dress
code rule is also fairly relaxed as
we've seen why don't we perform in so
many different outfits we love the
relaxed and comfortable outfit look
after all which more important is paying
attention to their amazing vocals
everything for our fans let's be honest
why don't we spans are absolutely
fantastic nobody
the passion they show for the band is
amazing so it's no wonder that why don't
we really appreciate their fandom if you
ever watch their videos you probably
notice that why don't we love to
surprise their fans while they're on
tour it pretty much gives them a chance
to visit new cities and meet as many
people as possible
we love celebrity surprise visits so
this is obviously absolutely perfect if
you follow them on Twitter you know that
why don't we love to interact with their
lime lights after all where would
singers be without their fans they're
the ones that purchase their albums and
stream their music
Jona even admitted that one girl gave
them a hand written 100 page book and
another fan gave Daniel 20 pairs of
underwear
they mentioned interaction and fan gifts
is one of the most amazing parts of
their tour so obviously every tour the
band makes sure they give back - are you
a limelight or do you belong to any
other fandom come let us know in the
comments below don't forget to tell us
your favorite why don't we song and
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]